[Musique]
j'ai attendu ce moment toute l'année
premier à l'autre
[Musique]
ma famille passent l'été dans la maison
de vacances de susanna sur l'île deux
cousines ce avec ses deux fils conrad
et jeremiah ils ont toujours vu comme
une enfant
mais cet été aura tout à l'heure ça va
changer
est vraiment ultra sexy arrête de
draguer ma petite soeur
qu'est ce tu fous respect du smic
c'est une invitation à participer au bal
des débutantes la ferme steven tout ce
truc de débutante c'est de la merde pour
les filles sans personnalité tu ne crois
pas que tu pourrais te montrer un peu
plus encourageants bon lesquels d'entre
vous va être le cavalier de bellio balle
hu
arrêtez vous battez pas pour moi susanna
m'avait dit qu'à ma naissance elle avait
su que j'étais destinée à l'un de ses
fils j'ai toujours espéré que ce serait
comme bref
on a failli s'embrasser concentre toi
mais bon y'a jeremiah les ma meilleure
amie parfois j'aimerais que ce soit plus
je suis censé faire quoi
pitié sortez moi de là
[Musique]
qui trouble beaucoup de cars belli
ça monte ça va ça vient mais l'amitié
c'est quelque chose de précieux
j'aimerais vraiment que tu sois là
ouais
tu te rends pas compte de l'effet que tu
peux avoir sur les gens comment on sait
quand c'est la bonne personne tu sauras
que c'est ça
[Musique]